مع كل يوم يمر بأزمة اللاجئين هذه
يزداد سوءًا ،
فقد أقام المهاجرون اليائسون هنا في
بيلاروسيا مخيمات ضد الأسلاك الشائكة التي
أقامتها بولندا لإبقائهم بعيدًا
عن حلم حياة جديدة في أوروبا في
الأفق ولكن بعيدًا عن متناولهم إلى أين أنت
ذاهب إلى
أين
عبر  إلى بولندا ،
ثم بينما كنا نستعد لتقرير مباشر ،
حيث ستتغير الحالة المزاجية على
وشك القدوم عندما استيقظ كل شخص
فجأة في مخيم اللاجئين هذا
على الحدود هنا بين بيلاروسيا
وبولندا فجأة وهم
يمسكون بأشياءهم وهم "  إعادة الانتقال إلى
موقع لا نعرف أين بعد ،
نحاول تحديد المكان الذي
ستذهب إليه ، وأين تذهب إلى
حيث البوابة ولكن الذهاب إلى بولندا
وما بدأ كقطر
أصبح فيضانًا
يبدو أن المخيم بأكمله
يحزم أمتعته ويتقدم على هذا التل
باتجاه نقطة التفتيش الحدودية بين
بيلاروسيا وبولندا ، ونرى
كل شخص يقوم آلاف الأشخاص
بتعبئة خيامهم وهم
يعبئون أيا كان.  لديهم الآن
ويمكنك رؤية هذه المشاهد المذهلة بقدر
ما أستطيع أن أرى هنا في المدخن الآن
مدى الرؤية التي حصلت عليها على
الكاميرا ولكن الجميع الآن يتحركون
بعيدًا عن المكان الذي كانوا يجلسون فيه
على طول هذا السياج الحدودي  هنا في
اتجاه الحدود البولندية
المبطنة للطريق ، رأينا
حراسًا روسيين يراقبون أعينهم ولا
يشجعون الحركة ولكن لا يوقفونها ،
نحن نتجه
نحو بولندا إذا فتحت بولندا الباب ،
سنكون سعداء بمعرفة ما إذا فعلوا ذلك ،
قالوا إنهم  لن يعلموا أنهم لا يعرفون
أننا لا نعرف جيدًا ، نذهب إلى هناك
ما سيحدث بعد ذلك ، لا أعرف
ولكن لا يمكننا الانتظار هنا
نذهب ونحمل أنفسنا هنا ليس لدينا أي
حماية نذهب  هناك إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي
عند نقطة التفتيش ، كنا نتجمع عبر
البوابات مع الحشد بين المهاجرين ،
ربما تنتشر شائعات من قبل البيلاروسيين
أنفسهم عن ممر إنساني
ربما يكون
مفتوحًا لهم لأطفالهم ، كان
نداء يائسًا
جيدًا هذا تحد مباشر  إلى
صناديق الاقتراع وإلى الاتحاد الأوروبي ، دع
هؤلاء المهاجرين يمرون عبر
سياج الأسلاك الشائكة هنا لأسباب إنسانية
أو دفعهم إلى الوراء ، لكن يمكنك أن
ترى رسالة من بولندا أنهم
نشروا
الشرطة بدروع مكافحة الشغب ، حيث
تقوم مكبرات الصوت الخاصة بهم ببث رسالة
تقول إنه يجب عليك  طاعة لتعليماتك
أو استخدام القوة ضدك ، وبالتالي
فإن السلطة البولندية لا تظهر أي إشارة
على الإطلاق للتراجع ،
إنه موقف لا هوادة فيه
، وبعد يوم من الأمل والدراما في
بيلاروسيا ، يواجه هؤلاء الأشخاص اليائسون
ليلة أخرى متجمدة.
على حدود بيلاروسيا بولندا